Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, although you may
know me from across the Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we are taking a look at two
brand new tools for building secure container
images. That is apko
and melange.
Joining us today from ChainGuard,
I'm gonna introduce us to these tools, show
us how to get started, and explain to
me why they're interesting because I'm not very
smart.
It's.
Hello.
How are you?
Hey.
Hey, everybody.
No. How'd you go? Please feel free to
introduce yourself.
I'm Ariadne.
I'm the
security chair for the Alpine Linux distribution, and
I'm
also
a software
engineer at.
And,
basically, I'm the
author
primary author of apko and melange.
So,
yeah, that's basically it.
Awesome. Thank you very much. I mean, it's
an absolute pleasure to have you here. I
mean, you've kept me hanging for months, if
not years, but I'm so glad that you've
Yeah.
Been able to come on and share some
of that knowledge with us today. So for,
you know, for me and for anyone else
that isn't familiar or aware of what apko
and melange are, can you give us, like,
the the high level overview before we, you
know, jump to the screen share and try
to understand what these things are?
Yes. So apko
is
a
image
composition tool.
It kind
of acts like Docker
in terms of you have a configuration file
that defines a bunch of things, and then
it spits out an image and publishes it
somewhere.
And then
the key thing about apko is that instead
of having, like,
things like the run statement or
copy statement or whatever,
it only
assembles images from APK packages.
The
reason why this is a big deal is
because
if you try to scan an image made
with Docker,
generally
speaking,
the scanners
can't
really see
all of the different things that have been
put into the image. Like, it can only
see, like, what's been
added to the image through various package managers
like APK or NPM or PyPI or whatever.
So
the idea behind apko is that if you
have an assembly tool that only deals with
packages,
then you can guarantee that the scanners
can scan
everything that's in the image because it's all
in the image, and it's all recorded in
the package manager database.
So
that that's a pko in a nutshell.
But
the other key thing about Docker is that
you can use it to build things
in sort of a cloud native way.
But as previously mentioned, if you build things
with Docker, then the scanners can't necessarily see
them. So Yep. You need you need a
second tool to
take code and turn it into an artifact
that can be processed by apko.
And
then when you combine these
two tools together,
you get something that can actually be scanned
100%
by, like, Trivy or Snyke or,
Encore, whatever scan tool you wanna use.
It it the key thing is that they
have the visibility.
So that that's basically what the tools do.
I love that you said a % and
then play it safe with, like, 99.9
or something like that. Like, it was just
this is it's gotta make sure that trivia
and all of that work well with us,
which is really cool. So I'm gonna try
and just make sure that I understood that
correctly. Is that the combination of apko
and melange mean that
and my repository where I'm building my super
million dollar application is that we could use
these two tools to turn that code into
an APK package,
which can then be turned into a container
image and published.
And it gets around this weird problem
that I think we've all had at some
point is that when we just copy random
binaries and take container image, all these scanning
things fall over. And does not fall over,
but they have no idea what it is
because they don't actually do
binary introspection or anything like that. They they
need to know where it came from
and the metadata about versions, etcetera.
These two pieces of software these
two pieces of software together give us that
traceability, visibility,
and so that's making sure that our container
images can be scanned with these these tools,
which is a really big deal. Like, this
is really important step for understanding
the security footprint of our applications when we
are shipping them to production.
Right. Exactly. And that's that's that's the point
is
making sure that the final stage in your
image composition
process is putting out something that is 100%
visible to,
the scan tools. And the other nice thing
about this is since you have all of
that visibility up front, you can actually,
at that time,
build what's called an SBOM,
which is a software build materials file.
And
if you have that up front, then you
don't have to worry about whether or not
a scanner is able to put it back
together after the fact.
So you can be confident
in
the results of your scan tools and the
results of your
SCA tools and so on. Because
if you're doing everything after the fact, then
you're missing things, basically. And
the other nice benefit to all of this
is Alpine images are already really small. But
since
we have these tools now, you can actually
build containers
that have
only the components of Alpine that you require
to support your application.
And so for an example,
we built an NGINX
Ingress controller,
container for Kubernetes,
just as a proof of concept, and it
weighs in at 8.3
megabytes
instead of
the 34 megabyte NGINX Alpine image or the
like, I think it's a 40
megabytes
NGINX Docker
images.
And
just kinda looking in the chat here,
I noticed that somebody mentioned Chimera,
and Chimera should already be
fully supported by apko
and melange if you want to use that
as your base
instead of Alpine.
Nice.
So,
I mean, Alpine images were already small enough
and being widely adopted because of their size,
and you've went, nah, not small enough. And
now we're stripping even more stuff out of
that. That's
that's pretty wild, but I like it.
So Yeah. The
the
the smallest proof of concept
image that I made with a prototype of
this tool last year,
I built a simple hello world application
that just contained Mucil,
LibC, and hell and the hello world application,
and that
clocked in at
around 400 kilobytes.
So
this tool enables
extremely small
images, like,
much smaller than
the Alpine base image.
Yeah. That's pretty cool. So, I mean,
I guess
what I
so you're just 400 k. Right? So does
that include a shell, or are we removing
the shell when we talk about this?
That removes the shell, and that's kind of
a security feature because if you don't have
a shell in there, then
you know, like, say that you have, like,
a WordPress container,
and then somebody
gets, like, r 57 shell p a not
PHP installed on it.
They can't then take that r 57 shell
and then get that to get an actual
shell and then root your container or whatever.
You know? If there's no shell there, then
it's already more
secure just from not having that attack surface.
Yeah. But there there are better approaches now
for when you do need to be able
to, you know, do debugs on production. You
know, have to control debug, which can add
a new container, web tooling, enter your pod.
Like, there's really no reason anymore for shipping
a shell inside of our application.
Exactly.
Awesome. Well, I'm really excited to play with
this now. So I am gonna pop over
to the screen share.
And all I have here is
I'll pay Linux 3.15
or three fifteen. I'm not sure.
First machine running on the node. I haven't
done anything else. I know we've got a
little bit of setup to run through,
but we're we're starting from scratch, which is
where you, the audience, would also be starting
from. So we're gonna show you every step
of the way how to to start playing
with these two tools together.
Cool.
Alright. So
I'm a first we're gonna have to update
to Alpine Edge because some of the tools
that we need are only available
in Alpine Edge right now. So
if you pull up the
repositories file
and then you've replaced the v 3.15
with Edge
for both of those repos,
and then we'll have to add the testing
repo as well.
Alright?
And then
yep.
And then, if you do APK
upgrade
dash capital u
and then a
and hit enter, it'll upgrade the distribution to
Edge,
which will take, like, two seconds.
Well, maybe a little longer on It it's
moving fast. Because there is most upgrades with
this stuff.
Well, that's that's one of the reasons why
people
enjoy using
Alpine is because the
package manager is
quite speedy.
Yeah. Definitely.
We wanna tackle a question just now. Are
you happy with that? Like
Yeah. I saw that Sam
asked in the
chat about
comparison to distroless.
And, actually,
the apko
and melange
stack
are intended to kinda be a spiritual successor
to distroless.
And don't worry. We're working on a GLIBC
version of it,
to support people who need GLIBC compatibility.
So
I'm just gonna give up trying to fix
my I don't know why my comments are
so huge and just taking over the whole
thing. Yeah.
So, basically, it's the same
concept conceptually,
and it's sort of meant to be a
spiritual successor.
Of course, Google's Distroless project
uses Bazel to build all of the base
images, and it's
really a pain to
deal with Bazel because
it's just it it's Bazel is very verbose
in terms of,
like, how you
actually use it to build the the legacy
Distroless images.
Like, you have to literally spell out each
detail, like, go download this dot dev file
with this checksum
and then this one and this one and
this one. And you have to actually solve
all the dependencies yourself by hand. So
apko
and melange,
it's built on APK,
and it uses the APK solver and all
of that. So it makes everything a lot
simpler in terms of
actually,
like, going from zero to having an image
versus with Distroless where you're
having to
write, like, three to 400 lines of Bazel
Starlark
configuration,
I believe.
I believe the configuration language of Bazel is
called Starlark. So you have to write, like,
three to 400 lines of Starlark in order
to actually, like, add new things
to
Distroless, and it's
so we decided,
you know,
let's kind of rework that to
simplify it. And
so that's how a p co a p
k o and melange
came up came about.
Nice. Yeah. I think Bazel is a really
phenomenal piece of software, but I just can't
use it. I find it too difficult, too
cumbersome.
I'm not a fan of Starlark, because we're
Python dialect.
I don't want the JVM on my machines
most of the time, so I just it's
it's not a tool that I feel comfortable
going through even though I appreciate
what it does and why like, you know,
companies like Google use it.
Yeah. So it's nice that there's there are
more more
alternatives to that coming up.
We got PGSA is still faster. Why am
I I give up the comments on this
thing.
Still faster than apt. Yep. We've got Nuno
following along in WSL two.
I'll move it one more time, but it
it just stay. Right? And then we've got
a question from John
John Sun Junior.
Any thoughts on how this was compared to
Next Day?
I think that's the the question. Are you
familiar with Next Day? I
have some passing familiarity.
So
if I'm right, I think Nixiri is the
thing that builds
images on demand with
Nick. Okay.
Great.
Yeah. We're
considering doing something similar. There's a service called
Contain.me,
which
builds a whole bunch of images on demand.
And
one thing that we're thinking about doing
is contributing,
like, an APKO
version of that so that you can actually
build
APKO
images on demand through Contain.me.
The apko
internals themselves are
designed
to allow
one to completely programmatically
drive,
like, the apko
image composition
composition engine.
So
building something like that would not be that
hard to do, and it is something that
is on a road map for APKO.
Alright.
Sam says thank you as well for that
very detailed answer. Yeah. Definitely.
Okay.
So slight segue there, but we have our
APK upgrade finished, like, a year ago. So
we're we're we're good. We can move on
now.
What are the the next steps?
Alright. So we're gonna have to install some
packages.
So
we're gonna need Go. Obviously, the tools are
built to Go.
Buildbase,
which is build dash base.
We're gonna need git to download the source
code, obviously,
And then we're going to need bubble wrap,
which is a lightweight container thing.
And then
we're gonna need fruit,
which is p r o o t.
Yeah. I've not heard of Bubble Wrap.
Bubble Wrap is from
Red Hat. It's the container
engine that's used by Flatpak.
Alright.
There we go. Learning lots of stuff today.
That's great.
Oh, we never got go1.eighteen,
so we can't use genetics yet.
Maybe next week. Well, the
good news is that
apko does not target go1.18
yet. So
Yeah. I mean, that only dropped yesterday, right,
I think? So
Yeah. I see a lot of buzz around
on Twitter. People seem to be very, very
excited about being able to use generic.
Yeah. It's gonna simplify
quite a bit of both apko and melange
to be able to use it, I think.
Pulumi too.
Yeah. We we have to wrap all of
our primitive types and Pulumi primitive type wrappers
so that
because there's a lack of genetics.
So that'll be a a nice change for
Pulumi in the future.
Jason's
saying, Dwight.
I'm assuming that's an office joke.
I I guess.
Alright. We got we got all those packages.
Alright.
So,
I mean, technically, we don't need fruit. Fruit's
only if you want to do things rootless,
but since we're keeping things simple, let's just
not bother with doing things rootless today.
I I I thought we're anyway, so we'll
just Yeah. So
the next step is to
well,
which one do you wanna play with first?
Because
there's kind of apko is pretty useful on
its own without having to
deal with melange.
So maybe it might be good to go
with apko
first and then
go through melange and then show how they're
combined at the end. So, I mean, based
on my my understanding so far, which
apko means we could right now
declaratively
build a container image by just point or
just using some alpine packages. Right?
Yeah. So if we just wanted to build
an engine x container image, we could we
could do that now?
Yeah. Yeah. Cool. Yeah. Let's see it in
action. That sounds great. Alright. So
the next step then is going to be
to download the apko source code, which is
at,
chain guard dev slash apko,
chain guard dash dev.
Oh, yep. Alright.
And then you can go in there, and
you can type in make,
a p k o,
and then hit enter, and it'll
make it.
And then
it's gonna download a whole bunch of stuff
here.
We got a comment from the notes saying,
not sure if this was intentional,
but melange equals mix in French, and melanger
is to mix.
That that was intentional.
The idea is that you can mix the
artifacts into an image and then
everything's scannable.
So that that's why I called it that.
Well, we're just waiting on some Go dependencies
right now,
which won't be long.
It'll it'll be about thirty
years because it's building Docker right now.
Oh. Well, parts of Docker.
Is it using BuildKit? Is it using other
parts of Docker? I'm not even sure if
I could name other parts of Docker now.
The parts of Docker that are related to
uploading
images.
Like,
we use Go container registry to actually compose
the images and upload them,
but that depends on Docker a little bit
to do some of the stuff. So
those are the parts of Docker that it
builds.
Yeah.
Well, I'm glad that when I spun up
the little node machine, I didn't cheap out
and go for the smallest one. I did
get, like, the
four cores and eight gigs of RAM, I
think. So that hopefully, that helps speed that
up.
Yeah. My my usual development
environment is these days is a 32
gig RAM line node with 16
cores and Nice. Apko
goes really fast on that. So it it
should go reasonably fast on this.
Well, it has built, I'm assuming.
Yeah. We got our apko thing here, and
we have some sub sub commands.
Yeah. So
if
we
let's see.
So if we look at, examples
slash NGINX.YAML.
Oh.
I mean, I just said nginx randomly. I
don't know if it's just gonna be sat
there in the examples directory waiting on this.
So that's serendipitous. I like that.
Yeah.
So this is
what we used to build an NGINX based
ingress controller
as a proof of concept for Kubernetes,
the one that I mentioned that was eight
megs earlier.
Mhmm.
This is it. So
we can actually build that and
import it into a local Docker instance if
you want to set up
Docker.
We'll do that in a second.
Now the interesting thing here is the service
bundle
entry point type, which is a
new innovation
for apko versus, like, Docker
or something like that,
a lot of people, they'll build, like, a
container that contains, like, two or three tightly
coupled services together, and
they'll all be in the same container.
And
so what this does is it will automatically
ensure that s six
gets installed,
and it configures it. And it sets up
the entry point where it just launches s
six.
So if you, like, build and run this
image, it will
run NGINX
under a supervisor
with s six running as PID one. And
Nice.
So it makes all of that a lot
simpler
than,
like, dealing with s six overlay or something
like that. It's just a nice,
declarative configuration
for the services that you want to supervise
with s six.
Okay.
Does Docker not have something similar where you
do
dash in it and it runs everything under
tiny, or is this different from that?
It does have the ability to run things
under Tiny,
but this is an actual, like, process supervisor,
which ensures that, like, if NGINX were to
crash or whatever,
it would automatically restart it. So Alright. Okay.
Okay. Gotcha. Plus, you could have multiple services
as well with the s six approach Exactly.
Which you can do with the container image.
Not that people should go crazy and throw
lots of different services into container images, but,
you know, there are use cases here. Sure.
Yeah.
Okay. So I'm I'm just gonna assume
that this might work.
Close.
I was I was making that up. But
Well, we have to go back into the
other directory,
or that'll work. Yeah.
So it's apko build
and then the config dot YAML file that
you want to run.
And then we can just call that, like,
a p k o dash nginx colon latest
or whatever you wanna call it.
And then,
like, a p k o nginx dot tar
because that's the thing that you can import
into Docker
if you don't wanna, like, publish or whatever.
And
if
you hit enter,
it will build the image for the local
architecture,
and it's done.
That's it.
That was fast.
And now if you, APK add Docker
and then
start the Docker service,
Yeah. Service Docker start.
And If you do Docker
Load. It's import? Load. Right? I can never
remember if it's or load. But
And then you do
the less than sign
and then, yeah, apko nginx dot tar.
The Docker daemon is not running.
Why is it not running?
You're looking there. I I think it was
just there.
Oh, no.
It's
check the
VarLog docker
log.
It might be something related to c groups.
Oh,
we're gonna have to
Okay. Go to ETC
APK repositories.
Open that up in
in
your editor of choice.
We need to bring back our
five point
3.15
kernel.
So
if you do 3.15
and then you put a tag at the
front of it, So
a
at the front of that line, if you
put at 3.15
and then space
Like that? At the front at the front
of it. Alright. Okay.
And then save it.
APK update.
Mhmm. And then APK
add
Linux dash vert
at 3.15.
And
then
Restart Docker? Uh-oh.
Are you gonna say reboot? Yeah. We might
we
might have to reboot it because it looks
like there was a kernel update in
since
Linode
built their
Alpine image. So
we're gonna have to reboot it, I think,
in order to get the necessary modules for
Docker to
actually start up.
Okay. Some Well, this is a a VM.
98 moments.
It it may be quick. It
usually
Comment. We should have just added pod man.
I I think that may have had the
same issue,
but maybe not.
Let's see. Did we go oh, we got
a few more questions there. So Nuno's looking
for hoodie.
I'll maybe run some swag giveaways soon, mate.
Nuno also said crane from gold containers is
definitely one gem that not many people know
about.
I guess that would be as a alternative
to using Docker's container registry package. Is that
what Nuno's suggesting there?
I'm not sure. Well, Crane Crane uses the
same Docker components that apko uses because apko
uses
Go Container Registry
underneath just like Crane does.
Okay. There we go.
Say I'm a bit late. Welcome.
And that was fast as a good tagline
for apko.
Yeah. Feel free to quote me. Stick that
on the website if you want. And Yeah.
Fucking IP tables.
It's always IP tables.
Yeah. Fucking networking. It's always hard, isn't it?
We've
got Devia, hey there. That's Welcome.
It it's it's because I forgot that there
was a security update for the kernel because
of the dirty pipe
thing.
So
Well, no. I don't remember that.
He's bragging that he doesn't have to reboot
with WSL too. So, you know, I'm glad
you're still following along.
I'm assuming
that should be available now.
Just assuming that the automatic
reboot
thing rebooted it.
I wonder if we've lost our machine.
Let's let's see.
I can pull up the Yeah. Linode content.
Sometimes Linode,
it doesn't re reboot. It just, like, shuts
it down.
Okay. I will reboot it from
oh,
is that I tried to reboot it from
the console, and it told me that the
the node is busy.
Yeah. I think it's already trying to reboot
it itself.
Let's just set up
some monitoring.
This is how I do my monitoring for
servers.
I mean, that's how everybody does the monitoring
Yep. Just
scrape that with Remetheus. Call it done. There
we go. There we go.
Finally, it's done rebooting. So
Alright. We'll just wait for SSH to start,
which will just be a moment.
I'll grab the password.
Yeah.
Alright.
So
if we
Perfect.
Start Docker now, it should work.
Yeah. That's a happy go. Okay.
Alright. Is that nothing So we're back then
to the apko slash examples.
We should have that a p k o
a p k o nginx dot tar, and
then we can load it in.
And
if you do docker,
run
apko nginx full latest,
it should start
the nginx thing up. Should I detach it
or just keep it front and center?
You can just go ahead and detach it
if you want.
And then if you do docker p s
so and then if you do, like, p
s three or whatever, it'll show that it's
all running under s six.
You
mean just on the host?
Yeah.
I thought e f would give me the
tree.
How would you get the tree?
P s tree.
Oh, really?
It's just one word.
Oh,
how have I not seen that command before?
Yeah. Is that an Alpine thing?
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh.
We're not not quite seeing what I think
we wanted to see. Is that right?
Or are we?
Should all still be it should still be
it should be running.
Yeah. It looks it appears to be running.
Oh, there you go.
Alright. So
we do have That nginx run. Right? Particular
that particular example container might be
might not be correctly running anymore because it's
kind of an older proof of concept, and
we changed a few things. So but
but as you can see, it
has s six running in it, and there's
NGINX inside it. And
Yeah.
So
Alright. We got a conference in Forest.
Is that really a thing you can pass
to p s? No.
Probably
on
some of them. Yeah. Okay. Like, if you
did APK add util dash Linux, it would
probably work. I'm I'm I'm not I'm not
that bothered. It's okay.
So let's recap that because
this was interesting.
We have
about a dozen lines of YAML, probably less.
We've got kind of two main components. First
one is called content, which will allow us
to specify Alpine repositories
and Alpine packages
that we want to get into a container
image.
So that's pretty nifty. We then got the
ability to do an entry point. Now this
is something new
that you're bringing to the table here called
service bundle, which will give us a supervisor
inside of our container,
and we can specify the services of that
we wanna start.
Now Yep. Just in the name of
why does it do that sometimes?
And the name of completeness,
I I have to really curious about whether
what is
fluffing my words because them is fluffing my
text.
What would a standard entry point look like
here? Like, just Ben followed by a path,
or can I can I still do this?
You can do entry point and then command
colon
and then whatever command you want to run.
So I could just do So, like I
know that path isn't correct, but but that
would that would just work as normal. Exactly.
And would that also take list of args
if they were required?
Or would it all just be blah blah
blah? It it would all be like that.
Yeah. Okay. Cool.
I like that. That's
that's nice. But it has that
that precondition
that we need to have our applications bundled
as APKs,
which is what you're gonna show us the
magic
melange for now. Right?
Yes.
So
Unless there was something else you wanted to
show with apko first, and I I I
don't wanna take it off. No. I mean
no. I mean, that's basically it.
Apko is just the assembly tool, and so
now now we get to see where
we can actually, like, start building our own
stuff to put into
an APKO
image.
And so
as a proof of concept,
we have
the GNU hello world program that we're going
to run-in a container.
And
Okay. So
I guess I have to make Milan by
typing.
Wow. Absolutely well. We have to build it
first, and then we're are we working through
one of the example directories?
Yeah. So
melange is a
pipeline
oriented
builder.
Like, if you're familiar with
GitHub actions or something like that,
then
this should all be fairly familiar to you.
So if we pull up, like, a the
GNU hello world examples, so that's an example
slash
GNU hello dot YAML.
There's just
two made
three major
components here.
First is the package metadata that gets
collected into
the APK
package metadata section.
And that includes,
like, you know, package name, version, what it
does,
and then, like, the copyright data and all
of that.
And then the second
section here is the environment section, and that's
literally
just the description of an apko image
that you want to build in order to
build
the package.
So, like, a base
like, a base image?
Yeah. You define your base image for the
build environment. Okay. Cool.
And then you have the pipeline,
and that's literally just like a GitHub action
style pipeline.
You can see that there's a bunch of
steps that use prebaked
tasks, and we have inputs for those tasks
like fetching. And then this is what the
SHA two fifty six is supposed to be,
and then we want to configure, make, and
make install it, and it's autoconf based and
all of that.
And then we have the sub packages section,
and that lets you run steps in order
to, like, split things out into
sub packages. Like, if you want to have
the main pages in a doc package instead
of
having it in the main package, that allows
you to slim down your
packages a little bit, which in turn allows
you to slim down your images.
And then each subpackage has its own pipeline
and metadata and so on. So
So
where do these use these
functions or targets
come from?
Those are bundled in the pipeline's
directory.
So if you get out of that
and we go back to the pipeline's directory,
you can kinda see, like, the fetch dot
YAML
one.
And
So there's a base one, a primitive pipeline
called run, which run arbitrary commands or scripts.
Exactly.
And we
replace
the expressions
based on our inputs,
and then
that gets
templated into a shell script, and then it
runs the the
fragment there in a shell. And
it's
it's basically
what you see on the screen there.
So what that does is it fetches the
thing,
and then it
does the SHA two fifty six comparison,
and then
it extracts it. And if any of these
steps in this
run fragment fail,
the pipeline fails
automatically.
So
and then the failures bubble up and
all of that. So
Cool.
Why the double braces instead of just, like
you know?
We didn't want to conflict
with normal shell scripting
variable substitution.
So
we have our own syntax
for doing variable substitution
in the actual, like, configuration
files
so that there's no
conflict,
conflicts between,
the shell and
all of that.
Cool. So
Alright. I'm gonna look at one more just
because I'm curious.
I'm assuming they're all
Yeah. Much the same. Cool.
Is there any other parameters beyond runs, or
is are all the other pipelines constructed from
our run statement?
It's just constructed from a run statement.
Okay. Cool.
So
if we go back to our examples,
I'm assuming
that we can run melange help, and it
looks very similar to what we got with
apko.
Yeah.
Except where you have some key gen stuff
too. I don't think I noticed that on
apko.
Well, because apko
is just a,
image composition tool.
But to, like, interact with the packaging system,
then you need to be able to, like,
sign packages and sign indexes and so on.
So
our first step
I would go back to the main directory.
Mhmm.
Our first step is we need to generate
a key pair to, like, sign all of
our things with.
So if you do melange
keygen,
it'll actually generate the key pair that we're
going to use.
And
if you look, you can see that there's
now melange dot r s a and the
melange dot r s a dot pub.
Those are just standard
x five zero nine
key pairs,
and there's nothing really that special about them.
Now we can actually build something.
So if you do melange,
build
examples slash g n u hello dot yaml
and then dash dash
workspace
d I r
equals,
like, work or something,
and then do dash,
and then do dash dash signing key
equals melange dot r s a.
It's signing dash key. Oh, right. Yep.
It's the r s d.
And then hit enter.
It should build GNU hello and
sign it.
Oh.
Oh,
right. Anything that melange the user
share?
We have to do
make install.
That that's the part we were missing.
Alright. Okay. Cool.
Alright.
So
now it should work.
Bad substitution.
That's
weird.
Go to
go
well, we can fix that real quick. Go
to
open nano or
open the user share melange pipelines
autocomf
configure
dot yaml.
Apparently,
the part that doesn't delete the inputs dot
ops
thing is not working correctly for some reason.
So if we just delete that,
it should work fine.
Kind of
that was working
earlier today,
but
oh, right. We had to delete the workspace
to reset everything.
So my work or something. Delete that. Yeah.
Alright. If we run it again, now it
should work.
And here, it's doing the apko step.
Nice. And there we go. Now it's working.
This is awesome. It it should be noted
that melange is not released yet. So
But I thank you for coming on to
show us that, it's it's it's going very
well.
We have an APK. So
so you now have,
some signed APKs.
And if we
create a repository
like, if you do
if you copy the melange dot r s
a dot pub to
e t c apk keys,
and then you do apk add
and then the hello dot apk,
it should install it.
And then if you do hello, you'll get
the GNU hello world program,
which
they managed to make a hello world program
that compiles to a 500 kilobyte package.
So
yeah.
So we have an APK here.
Now the next step
would be,
I guess, to make a container that has
that hello world package in it, which
should answer
a mean's question.
He was
they were asking about
circular dependency.
And the answer is no. There's no circular
dependency because,
melange only depends on the apko
go package. It doesn't depend on the apko,
like, command itself.
So
they're otherwise completely independent tools of each other.
if we
go and make a directory somewhere,
doesn't really matter where.
Okay.
And then we make a apko
dot yaml file.
Was it packages?
It's contents.
Damn.
Alright. And
then we do repositories
colon,
and then we do, like, HTTP,
you know, the usual Alpine one,
d l c d n
Alpine Linux Org. Copy it.
Okay. Yeah. That that works. And then
Do we need we replace either of these?
The base We do need to keep,
Alpine base layout.
And if we do hello,
and then if we go
up
to
the first one, to the repository section, we'll
make a local work we'll make a local
repo. Mhmm.
And we can have that, like, in
slash home
slash
or, like, wherever you're gonna put it,
root slash repo.
Sure. That works.
You don't actually have to use the file
colon slash slash. I would just recommend having
it as slash root slash repository.
Yeah. Okay.
And then we can just do, like, entry
point user bin hello.
Like, the command. It it still needs to
be defined. You were showing me some fancy
Sorry. Hand there.
User
Not yet, but soon.
Like so.
Yeah. And then save it.
Alright. So the next thing we have to
do is actually set up a repository.
So make DIR repository,
and then go in there and then make
DIR x eighty six sixty four.
And then
go in there.
If we copy the
APKs for the melange directory
okay. Now if we do APK
index
dash dash output,
apk
index dot tar dot it has to be
capitalized. Sorry.
Oh, yeah. Like, a p that's right. Yeah.
Dot tar.gz,
space star,
space star.a
p k,
and then hit enter.
Okay.
Now we have to sign that,
which we're going to use melange to sign
it.
So if you do melange
sign dash index
and then dash dash signing key
equals root melange dot melange dot r s
a dot pub or dot r s a
rather,
and then a p k index dot tar
dot d
dot tar dot g z,
it'll sign it.
Okay. Now we have a signed index.
If you go back to the directory of
our apko
dot
yaml file
Jitter.
Yep.
We can now do
we can now run that a p k
o dot YAML using the a p k
o build command.
I don't think we may can stop that.
So I'm gonna have to do a p
k o a p k o
build. Yeah. We didn't.
And then it was just the failed. Yeah.
And then hello colon latest and then
hello dot tar or something.
Do I need to add my
no. Oh, right.
Right. Right. Right. Right. Right.
You have to do,
go go up
and bring that
or no. No. No. No. Go back to
the new DIR.
Bring that apko command back up
because we have to actually add the
Yep. Yeah. That one.
We have to actually add the
key to the trusted key ring. So it's
a p k o build dash k.
Is that for n secure?
No. That's the add of the key. Alright.
So it's dash k
and then the
e t c a p k dot
or e tcapk
melange R p r s a dot pub.
Yeah. That.
It should work.
There we go.
Alright. So we now have a hello dot
tar
with the hello world package in it.
And if you do docker load
and if you execute it, it should say
hello world
in theory.
Ta da.
Nice. And that is a one megabyte
container.
Yeah. That's pretty trim.
So
That's cool. That's a p k
that's APKO
melange and then a how apko and melange
are used together.
Very, very cool.
Obviously, like, in a enterprise,
like, so called secure software factory,
you would have, like,
actual repository
management instead of, like, using a local repo,
ideally. But
setting all of that up, it would not
be fun for,
like Yeah. A single episode of Rawkode Academy.
So
I feel a bit silly for asking
you from Alpine Security working for chain guard,
from apko, melange, and s bombs and all
this stuff. If dash k was the same
as curls and secure.
I'll edit that out for sure.
But that's really cool. I love that
we can
have this workflow
where we build APKs, we build emojis,
and we get the stain and verification
all the way along. And we have a
question about the about the s bomb, so
I'll get to that in just a second.
But this is just a really cool workflow.
I'm assuming that, you know, given a bit
more time,
there'll be GitHub actions and
that it's gonna make this really, really easy
for people to get started.
Is that the plan? So,
yes, so for apko,
we already have GitHub actions. Like, if you
go to the distroless organization
on GitHub,
you can see that we're actually rebuilding the
Alpine
base image based on whatever is an Alpine
Edge every night. And that's fully done with
GitHub actions.
And
the way that we've set this up is
people should be able to go and reuse
these actions
without any problem. We have a template repo
up,
for example,
that
has everything that you need.
And
that's a good starting point.
Thanks, obviously, to at
for
doing the legwork on the template repo.
But if you use that template repo, you
can have automatically
refreshed images
every night.
And it'll go and it'll sign them with
cosign,
and, like, every single part of the pipeline
will be, like,
ideal for
the supply chain security
aspect of it because
you'll have images that can be scanned,
and then they'll be
always up to date. And
it'll be
yeah. It it'll be always up to date,
and it'll be
scannable.
And
as you can see here, it's not that
complicated to do.
Yeah. It feels to me, like, haven't walked
through this with you now. There's only one
part that I think can't really be ephemeral,
and that would be the key gen step.
Right? That would be something that we did.
We do once and we store as a
GitHub action secret or in some other secure
place, like like Vault or something. Right? Then
that would be a pair of key.
You you would use something like Vault
ideally. Like, if you were going to use
melange to, like, have automatically
built APK repository
for the public to use, You would use
something like Vault and integrations
for managing APK,
assigning material if Vault already exist. Yeah.
So
And the other thing there would be the
the APK repository that we created. I mean,
that could be a femoral. That doesn't need
to be maintained or long lived. It could
that can only exist during the CICD process.
Is that is that fair? Correct. Right. Okay.
Correct.
But, I mean, if you want it to
be permanent, there's stuff like JFrog,
artifactory,
and
stuff like that that already supports
managing
APK repositories.
So there's there's no shortage of options out
there
for
all of that. And,
obviously, we we would like to hear
people's opinions on what's already out on the
market for managing
APK repositories
in a corporate
setting
because
I
have opinions on it. But
Okay. Let's tackle a few more questions that
we've got today.
So we got one here
from
g I could one. Do things that are
fetched or added using pipeline stage Like, this
get added or are they represented
in the bill of materials?
Not yet.
Right now,
the Alpine ecosystem is still using APK version
two,
which does not really support capturing
all of that data yet.
But APK version three does.
And
once everything switches over to APK version three
ecosystem,
all of that will be in the SBOM
for free.
That that's our intention anyway.
Alright.
Let's see.
We got
ta da.
We got I agree. Oh, no. My comments
are just coming in the middle again. Thank
you.
Creating a local repo in Nortem just out
of memory. Yeah. I was impressed by that
too. The fact that you were just pulling
these plucking these commands out of your head.
But I guess you did this DND out.
Right? This is
Well, I mean, it it does help when
you, like, made a lot of this stuff.
We got a wave
at
yep. Converted all emojis to melange and apko.
Yeah. I'm gonna be right behind you there.
This is a really impressive tool chain. And
it's so early. It's it's cool to be
just seeing how this evolves as well.
Yeah.
Especially if melange, there there's a lot that's
still subject to change,
but we're hoping to have, like, a release
out
pretty soon.
There's a couple of other
initiatives
that are in the pipeline for
my team at Shingard to kind of figure
out first.
Like
like I said, we kinda see all of
this as a spiritual successor to Google's distroless.
So
if if you think about
Google's distroless as, like, distroless one,
this is, like, distroless two that we're building,
basically.
And so we're kind of trying to come
up with some ways to
ease the transition away from Distroless one to
Distroless two.
So
at the moment, those are the things that
are kind of getting ready to take priority.
But
the hope is that we'll have a
early
preview release of melange out later this week.
Wow. Quick.
And then apko 0.2,
which we walked through using is also due
out this week. So
that's kind of
the pipeline there. And then we're doing some
similar tooling for Debian to kind of support
the
legacy distroless
users as
we try to evolve the Distroless ecosystem
in this direction.
And
Is this you know, it's hard to tell
with the with with the projects we're still
in this this kind of discovery phase and
rapid evolution, but is this something that people
can get involved with? Are you looking for
contributors to come along and even provide feedback
or write code? Yes. You are. Yeah. Absolutely.
We've already been merging patches from external contributors.
I think, PJ
earlier in the chat, he's one of the
external contributors
that has contributed code to
apko.
And then there's another big contributor that's outside
ChainGuard that's contributed a lot to both apko
and melange
named Cruskal,
and we're trying to, like,
always get more people involved in in the
project. We
fully understand at that
we need to do all of our work
in a fully open source way. And
so everybody's welcome to participate
and Awesome. Contribute, like, ideas,
bug reports, patches, whatever they want to do.
Cool.
We have a a couple more questions then,
and then we'll
we'll wrap this up. We got one from
Moz
saying, sorry. I joined late. I'm curious if
melange can be used to send Docker images.
Now I must have been melange is using
cosign
to to the same input, or is that
wrong?
Melange
just uses
the APK style RSA signatures to sign packages.
Packages.
To sign, like, a Docker image, you would
use cosign,
which
that uses all the Sigstore infrastructure.
And
SigStore is kind of the modern way of
doing it.
One thing that I will say is that
we are kind of looking at a way
to integrate in the SigStore full CO style
signatures into APKs
so that you can have the keyless signing
instead
of having to deal with
having, like, a key in in stored in,
like, Vault or as a GitHub action secret
or whatever.
But that's gonna take some work on the
APK side to do first. So
Cool.
Alright.
And is
asking, would you mind explaining the intent behind
the distro listing?
Can we achieve the same thing by building
images from scratch based images?
Right.
So
the point behind Distro is is that
you can take
just the components out of a software distribution
that you actually need to support an application
and have it done automatically.
So
you can do things
like build a statically linked binary
and then copy it over into a scratch
image.
But the problem there is
that if you do that, like, the tooling,
like, Trivy and
Snake and all of those scanners, they will
not understand
what's going on, and they won't know how
to scan it.
So
by using this distroless technique and capturing everything
into packages,
you can have full transparency
to the scanners, basically.
And that's a powerful thing
because right now, the scanners miss
a lot of details because they can't see
the app that you're trying to scan.
Yeah. With the statically linked binary, you you
don't know if you're using a version of
open SSL for instance that has some current
CVE
Exactly. Problems with your application. That's that's the
problem in the space that these tools are
are trying to solve and why they're so
important.
Alright. Well, we're all out of questions. Is
there anything else that you would like to
show or share before we wrap up for
today?
I think that's it.
Awesome. Well, thank you so much for taking
time out of your day and for coming
on to kind of walk us through this.
I really am really excited by this, and
I can't wait to start kicking the tires
on it. And it's just really
chilling in a space that can hopefully pry
us away
from the the Docker file and all these
other convoluted build tools. So very exciting. Yeah.
Absolutely.
And
it's been good coming on the show, and
hope to do it again sometime.
Alright. Well, have a great day. I'll speak
to you soon, and thank you again.
Have a nice day. Alright. Bye.